hi it's Michelle from Latin life and
beauty science and right now I'm in the
decime store with me education associate
first rally and co-founder and CEO so
Nicola how did you get into the beauty
of skincare business so when I to
university I was haunted by boots from
the UK which is one of the biggest at
beauty will help you to retailers and
that high McBride hood so out working
his immunity buyer when used with his
previous at that skin can continue in
labs and then when he left indeed lovers
and you want to start deci online one
person really them it was too exacting
many analogies though I'm doing in 2013
when it was founded and yet is really it
became more than we ever could have
grown command as a senior
[Music]
so I did more equality at 80 so I've
always been a bit of a science geek and
when I worked in the lab it was really
interesting because I'll start to see
projects they pulled me into cosmetics
and so I wasn't really like I wasn't
aware that side of Marie could be
possible sorry I moved to Sydney and I
ended up you know down the rabbit hole
and you we are not just always been
really fascinating how the molecules
work now it's going beyond worry now it
is like how newer technology is working
for us and how we can utilize it so it's
an exciting definitely exciting time
what are the best-selling density of
products so our bestseller was
everything's nice and mind and listen we
sell one needs a night every third to
step in laughs and I think if we could
keep it in my cellar and now it comes in
a jumbo size which is amazing so nice in
wine has been really popular cause it's
fantastic behind a bit any mineral base
serum so not only is it good for your
oily finish priming or congested see it
times it's actually quite high drain if
old rules moisture into the skin
you've got the addition of zinc as well
as in PCA so that's excellent at taking
down any redness or formation in the
skin and we find that niacinamide as
well over time actually helps with the
overall trends in so for someone like
myself you can get the look of dark
spots after blemishes it's been great to
eat me now which decía product was a
surprise success where any of those of
my successes do you just notice well the
older me as a brand was deadly surprise
success so we want the orderlies to make
the points as far as in the other kind
of crown lord it consists in keratin
it's really looking at many future
technologies have advanced thinking can
be its focus on skin health skin
integrity and actually brown women in
the team they get frustrated when they
see these incredible products in
creating that makes it other
it's not that the other products didn't
work is that other brands were chatting
about bitumen see Nemo Galactus it's not
a great ingredient but actually that's
not say that this is innovative moon
actually it shouldn't be packaged that
way and also we've seen how expensive
they were being mobile we like we
thought frustrated but neon genuine was
so kind of groundbreaking because it
again to Apache but glitz stroke
consumers if you want these ingredients
that do rework they're really trusted
they don't need to be expensive and they
don't leak and shafts as new
technologies but we never expected the
over you to really become what it has
become
was there anything you as the price
player in the Sydney's door that's all
really well the multi peptide serum for
hair density you you ordinary so when we
launch that product in Sydney it's
literally sold out so that was fantastic
to see the responsible a hair care
product underneath you
ordinary honey that was really exciting
for us though more hair care products
curry for the Londoners and so which is
one of our much we're going to rearrange
in your journey there's a couple more
feminine hair embody this are in
development mission
hopefully 20/20 little starts thing
which the steel product you think is
currently under agent I definitely want
to give a shout out to African issues in
the Harlem I'd range so we have a
photography foundation which is a skin
Perfector as well so it has different
technologies in there so it essentially
deflects and absorb different
wavelengths of light so you actually get
a really blurred even in facial skin you
can mix up with your car club actually
you can use up without I can even use it
on top of your foundation itself so it
comes in three different tints there the
transparent which is like a pearlescent
teeth so you can use it and not have to
worry about some sort of a bronzey face
and then we also have a golden tan in
duck tan and I think you mean chemistry
friend we have a carbon concentrate
which is just a big tub of hyaluronic
acid for that which is just amazing that
you can apply all over your body and it
really just helps to hydrate the skin
and I loved about you only how to use it
two or three times women keep your body
hydrated what are your personal favorite
desert products so for me it has to be
I'm the odd company me no ISIL in Syria
that's the walnut I just couldn't live
it now but then also I found multi
molecular harmonic complex in New York
I've got 50 different types of
hyaluronic acid technologies there is
the to die crank if it's my stables AM
and PM and I tend to Train
often there's new products that I've
been trialing and I'll then add on top
of this for myself I definitely go for
five no mud mask in the answer again I'm
an oily congested skin trust I love how
everything out it's not drying on my
skin as well and again great for I
definitely can't go past my center mine
we need the ordinary and I definitely
love the vitamin C powder and well again
briny you can kind of see them with me I
feel like if like being Asian I get tons
of pigment and I have also obsessed with
fading pigment because when it comes it
just never leaves
yeah totally feeling tobecome we do get
a lot of black D pop maybe all these
patients skin torian's coming in and
that's a quite a major concern is like
as soon as there's a blemish or some
sort of trauma to the skin the post
inflammatory pigmentation is an issue
and now we definitely have products that
can target the look of and that
pigmentation is also giving people some
options so what I have been here in
beauty routines depends on where I am if
I'm working later
maybe her license I have wheeler
everything so it's kind of up and down
it depends up there love especially if
it's on the weekend then I have time and
I'd love to do like a mud mask and
really take the time to you a few
different steps if I'm kind of taking
the time at home and sometimes I'll find
that actually my morning routine I'll
try to leave a bit longer in between
each place and maybe I'll wake up our
pens I'll apply something in our first
four teams in the place on the yellow
beverage my head and come back in the
plane to the serum so for me just
depends on how much timing yeah it's a
very similar to new claw it depends on
the time if I have a very very very long
retain that I was doing double cleanse
I'll do appeal in there then I'll lay
out my serums if I'm short on time
which is most mornings and I have to put
on ice in a wine at least at least some
sunscreen and then I'm out the door what
is it like being a female CEO in the
beauty industry because we hear a lot
about how the beauty industry it's lots
of women but at the top it's mostly men
yes you're very fortunate that in in
both groups in destiny I've never felt
any gender bias and I think exciting for
the future of all that I think there are
more modern companies like this in more
actually it literally does not matter
gender age it's just about who's kind of
best for that role and you know since I
became a mother it's definitely you get
you have more pulls on your time and
it's hard when you really see the best
of both drugs and I think you know the
thing I really want to work with that
I've seen one is having
great return policy because they zoomed
out and you have a baby as apparently
suddenly are trying to juggle more
things we should you shrink to
prioritize everything in your life and
then thinking of one of the things that
I have found that's many easy enough to
give me the balance we are what used to
be frustrating that we had officers open
24 hours identity of offices in New York
Melbourne Sydney Korea London it was
always small was working and now find a
benefit because actually me logo spread
at 7 p.m. it's only 2:00 p.m. in Toronto
and Omega house nothing yet on a call
but that means I can maybe have the
afternoon off with Mila and but really
we just were in that really disrespect
each other regardless of gender or Asian
feel very fortunate to be in this
position so what is coming to Joseon so
we've got some exciting new launches and
so probably my personal well as I've got
Sherman personally very a bustling exit
from the other launching out of copper
amino isolate lipid so this would be an
evening at treatment this blue color
comes from the new concentration of
copper peptides in here and now CIF
summary the hair product we have
everything needed estimates on that I
think all of our team or very loyal to
would really believe in and and this is
from the same family at the tha copper
peptide but this is a liquid version
which has a higher affinity to the skin
as this would be an evening treatment
and actually when you use CIL would say
in night and wouldn't even meet you to
have a monster when using this one of
the ingredients that it's from a family
of the derivative so yeah that's better
than this mask comes from at this is
work we must image within you could you
see is nominee is
so CAI Ansel in Australia we like call
it cats to do one so custard one is your
copper peptide but also pure peptide
serum so if your [ __ ] back times
excellent because they've found actually
in the other members get lots of
different functions as well so great at
synthesizing collagen we want a bit more
collagen and elastin as well
we've got supporting technology in there
so that in cancers as well learn and
copper peptides so that's a fantastic
serum for overall skin health above them
below surface aging on the skin and it's
in an interesting format so it is it
like a true bottle if it's separated so
the ingredients is fresh and possible so
when you crack it open and you mix the
activating in and you shake it that's
when it's pretty see most afresh and
then you get this blue color tutorial
comment peptides and then you can see
this actual to this formula they're
really just industry into the skin so
then in the autumn everyone watching a
concealer service comes in 21 shades
very highly pigmented and actually we
decide seem really which poses to
understand the nature of the skin and
how the micro vibrations work that she's
to come up with a matrix which means it
weren't sinking to instruct one lines
wrinkles and this will be passing the
ten or $18 and Restylane see ya
coming on 20 objects that we have the
current range of colors in so the color
that we have two categories so we've got
the coverage which is a medium to full
coverage it's beautiful it's designed so
that the pigment quite like this in get
not sinking into any pores or white
lines or texture and they work really
synergistically together and then we've
got our serum foundation more liquidy
texture as well
less pigment so you get that lighter
medium coverage some people mix or two
or you can use one in the daytime serum
in a daytime coverage in the night time
and those super balls give types as well
and again the shade rate is fantastic
for all times
what sort of format will the conceal
little bit will reveal then any given
issue hollow awesome and then we also
miss April time we'll be launching our
STX for in Australia is a launch
so we have SPF 30 and SPF 50s the 50 is
mix of chemical and mineral so with the
50 there's a very slight white custard
it really not much at all and then the
30 is visible and then you'll also we
don't have some funny about our but we
are launching our pomegranate and enzyme
extract and willow bark which will give
you assist its gonna be on time to
nourish it's more at food place and thus
moving on Street alley
awesome finally got our baby front
launching yes either because he is gonna
be launching at the beginning of next
year and I have my little baby domes and
who's been testing these four explorers
this is that bin milk it's squalid base
it's a really nice light moisturizer so
we won't go too heavy on the brainless
skin and muscle even they have said same
thing I feel perfectly people have five
ingredients or less and fantastic how do
you decide which products to launch next
switch internally thinkin in the lab
when we create products a lot of them
actually come out of the lab and I think
one of the things that makes us
different is our and PD development II
sit as part of technical not as hot
branding or marketing because that's for
me I think she really get true
innovation if it comes from the
scientists they're telling you that
we've seen this or develop this and
actually that's what's really exciting
at one of the ways we will keep
creativity still one of our brands are
anomaly that we say it's the brand
promise bit and so anything that doesn't
quite fit
elsewhere in looking up normally and it
allows us to keep creativity because for
example one of the things you want to
work with is a hyaluronic mouthwash now
we'll never have a dead foreground
because it just wouldn't make you a mess
but actually your exciting technologies
and that's now something that can stand
up not only with all news so what else
is next for DES iam so in Toronto we've
just moved into our new headquarters
which is 70,000 square foot facility and
in there we'll have all of our lab
moment a moment Center people are
working attacked boolean research or
developmental testing or regulatory and
then we've got
19 so it was just going to be in this
amazing space and it's nice because
Brandon actually picked that up that
something lots of syrup design than they
have and then we're also going to be
launching a store which will open in
spring minute in 2020 so consumers will
be able to come to the store and
actually see in it's the opposite and
hopefully be able to see the products
we've made as well
we believe in full transparency so we're
excited that continues to be able to see
what we do thank you so much for talking
to me min and Nicola thank you for
having us thank you